[музика]
всім привіт європейська солідарність
активного проти будинку дістаньте ну ми на
проти нього поки що і в законопроекті столітті
про найм ви нас ти на подачі вова
сесію вас чаєм потягнув настав вигляд колою
сбу набивши 6 дуже видно ще речового
сесія вигляд будете вона прикиньте терават
і дружина і наша позиція йєнн зраду і в
порядку дену може стоять і терпіти і
закони та кіно правди не на прохання скоро
ну вірусом на Петро їм кури і вони повіку по
суті завищувала сезар із вас
фінансування алаю беруть на себе
основні тягою за раз боротьби з
епідеміями у своїх регіонах місцях
забезпеч як і так вже будьте закон ще
100 суїцидів ринку української економіки
джоні законопроект таки відсоток на
розкол suspense твоє ким може праворуч
сорому масових заварушок з буринь
масових зборів вони про порожні c
випадкового і закон про землю річки та моря
викл і ктс буріння і в Москві де броня
на годину і підніметься повинен і безтурботно
овочі пак і за неспокій не виникає ще
може за 1 проти ти і закони так дзвони
ще 100 suede сенненського доки ця я
відриваюсь одні десятки свинки вид
журналістів проходь дати коментар ключ
цієї себе в прямі ефіри підготовкою до
відеоконференції
25 березняка вигляд буде театру сторонні
контактні групи я хочу сказати ще
батьки самі відеоконференції нічого не
звучного німа і в стрибні руки ми на
ритку проводив і терміналі
відеоконференції часто ви можете самі
україни самої української сторони алла
диявол завжди криється в деталях
ми вимагали і проведення конференцій
випробувань би спарка активка я адже
бувало сюди про країну на фронті я катер
виду волосся масу повік обстріли
українських ризикових чек цивільних
населених пунктів c ми українська
сторона
допомагав in linear акції на наших
колег за крима a b c ми вимагали та
проведення конференцій для того, щоб і
у вигляді шляхом нас
адже сидонія по видному обидва з я
піднімалася про ітан я доручення росію
мінських догляд за кримами харчування bespeco
так само ми проводили і такі дістаньте
не тлумачення курка зажадав цього
точно не
спуску за ручні керчі інших актуальних
тим і проблема так я включав посідають з їх
відеоконференції засідку точки в почеті
нас правді спілкуватися зажадала за хоч
то цікавий громадян України ще навіть
на бік відеоконференції як буде
25 б життя ці ключові моменти там є
вершина, що ворожить два-три дні тому
українська сторона підписала в мінську та
кисть протокол на я кому говориться про
розчину не опорну консультаційну
раді dvd-диск представнику україни 10
просто якимсь орлом і тільки по одному
представлений потім вид околиць
брати участь нормандського формату токто і
вид росії ціни 2 чайни вона безтурботно там
ще тристороння контактна група з
над розумом і трас троне рахунках я україна
україна жертва агресії росія україна
агресор і обидва з я я коли я роль
модератора на увазі ж ваш кий
дипломатичні вирок ній роботі ти
пізніше по суті висновки cb в одну
лінію себе в нас три просто
модератором цілого процесу інша
росія та крему лексіти рок ipad що
фавели нас до прямих переговорів з
донецькому та луганському для того щоб
поривчастий дискурс мінських залі прямого
ну ось ще ви б рахунки в Україні йди за
кремлівським сценаріям романський конфлікт
всередині шнива на інших айван ігорок між
Ціни правда у нас і агресія
Російської Федерації цього висновку це
бойовик і як павутиння вирок на бік
розум з України ціною повинен і безтурботний
часто нам загадає так ви майже це ж ви
так мінську там злочинниці уявити і
так там де люди і ті закупи ван їх
території
дуть на кіпр імован і через москву від
рибалити вас інструктаж у крим чи у фсб
секціях суркових ти парк про заку іван і
там в ікону цю роль собак річки просто
озвучують позицію кремля
олов'яні повноцінними учасниками
прямий він так ми збентеження барана вівці у
примітках мис чоловікові
вириті сні ми там прозі ручники для того
щоб надати тих людей ранку йому
лайки
сьогодні знаходиться в котельник орлова без
легких умовах ми вимиємо у допуску
червоного христа туди і вріжте rest
ну для того ніж вибачте людей очевидно
шукаю потрібного червонувато всі механізми
alavann інші повноцінними учасниками
переговорів
ніколи не які на документах річки
наказувалося а мінську не стояли там
таких текст ще цільтеся повноважні
представники по суті ти нею papers in
цем-цем документам протоколом так званим
і кипить посолимо і мінськ поїхав і або
завали ось легалізував і з їх самозванцями
у маріонеток кремля записавшись його немає
та повноважні представники з її назвою
чайна та призначаючи на безтурботно дали ще й
душа і має забезпечуватись польші
протокол і кипить піщаним мінським даними
а я слова про bespeco купа дзвонити його
відчули кбр з нержі
заглянула 18 українських скронь із ким
поспішає цифра тяжі хл його цифра видно
на пробитися 40 українських ризикових та
очевидно ще не якихось прямих переговорів
ведмедик і вам і
окупованою донецькою та луганською
ніби не можеш цін чайного лика
полку нам і треба говорити так само
нашого опонента ці зарості владу ще
теж ви підписали мінську та протоколи
допиту але чим а це озвучує це
українську законодавчу дату великих
розумів наказував насіння scale і адже
бувало сила війська трагедія акули і йшли
бої за дебальцеве і очевидно ще
ключовим завданням нашої команди було
porsche та західної to be new друга
погляду коло за колом
українську територію -
жорна метра української землі та
владні миколи негараздів ніяких
тексті в українських законів
бойовикам та з росії
[музика]